Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 264. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich werde heute aber nicht so heißen und ich bin so alt, dass ich eigentlich keinen Bock mehr auf diese Sendung habe. Und warum, das erklären wir euch heute ganz ausführlich. Es geht nämlich um das Aufweichen von Verschlüsselung. So, ich bin heute Monoxid, weil das mein Twitter-Handle ist und weil wir sonst in der Sendung wahrscheinlich Probleme kriegen. Denn bei mir zu Gast ist Markus. Hallo, Markus. Also Markus Drenger, um genauer zu sein. Jemand, der auch im CCC ist, der sich sehr viel für netzpolitische Themen interessiert und auch dazu arbeitet. Also nicht im Sinne von Erwerbsarbeit, sondern im Sinne von Aktivismus. Außerdem zu Gast, Anne Roth. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Netzreferentin, nee, was? Referente für Netzpolitik der Bundestagsfraktion Die Linke. So was ist richtig, oder? Und wir sprechen außerdem mit Julia Reda, ex-Europaparlament-Abgeordnete, jetzt bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, die Leiterin des Projekts Control, Urheberrecht und Kommunikationsfreiheit. Die kommt aber später dazu, aber wird auf jeden Fall heute dabei sein. Warum sind diese Menschen heute hier? Und warum sprechen wir über die Aufweichung von Verschlüsselung? Na ja, es hat sich also zugetragen, dass und das Geräusch im Hintergrund, die nahende Sirene, passt genau dazu, dass der Ministerrat der EU ein Schreiben ausgegeben hat. Und da steht, und da wird es schon spannend, da steht nicht direkt drin, lass uns mal bitte die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bei den Messengern aufweichen, sondern da steht, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, in den Gesprächen, die ich jetzt darüber geführt habe, da steht was ganz Schwammiges drin, dass man aber eigentlich, wenn man Ahnung vom Thema hat, nur lesen kann als, lass uns doch mal die Verschlüsselung, die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung bei den Messengern aufweichen. Bevor ich jetzt meine Gäste zu Wort kommen lasse, möchte ich zwei Dinge tun. Einmal um Entschuldigung bitten. Das Thema Aufweichung von Verschlüsselung ist mega alt und die Kämpfe dagegen sind mega oft geführt worden und ich versuche das in diesen Sendungen immer zu vermeiden, aber vielleicht passieren heute Referenzen auf Dinge oder ihr verspürt so ein gewisses Abgegessenheitsgefühl, wie wenn man einem Kind zum tausendstmal sagt so nein, nicht das Ding essen, was auf dem Fußboden lag, das ist nicht so gut. So und das andere ist Ende-zu-Ende-Verschüsselung, ganz ganz kurz am Anfang sozusagen erklärt, was das bedeutet. Ende-zu-Ende-Verschüsselung ist etwas, das ihr übers Internet schickt, kann nur der lesen, an den ihr es schickt, sonst niemand. Bei Messengern heißt das also, ihr habt einen Messenger, jemand, den ihr kennt, hat einen Messenger, dem schickt er eine Nachricht und niemand sonst weiß, was da drin steht. Niemand, nicht mal der Betreiber des Messengers. Das ist der ganz ganz ganz wichtige Punkt. Und warum das wichtig ist und wie man das kaputt machen kann, das besprechen wir heute. So, ich weiß gar nicht, mit wem ich jetzt anfangen soll. Ich stelle euch mal die Frage, dann könnt ihr euch ausruhen, wer antwortet, was genau war das denn eigentlich für ein Papier? Also was genau steht drin? Ich hab ja so ein bisschen drum rum geschwafelt jetzt, aber was für ein Papier fordert da eigentlich genau was?
Ich will kurz erklären, woher die Frage kommt. Nichts macht das Sinn, sich dagegen zu wehren, die der eigenen Bezügerung widersprechen. Aber es könnte auch der Eindruck entstanden sein, der politische Alltag ist unter anderem auch. Es gibt immer wieder Leute, die Verschüßlung folgen. Dann gibt es andere Leute, die sagen, das ist Quatsch. Und deswegen die Frage, ist das einfach so eine Diskussion, die einfach immer wieder läuft, oder ist es sinnvoll, jetzt in diesem Moment aktiv zu werden?
Ich denke, es ist sinnvoll, jetzt im Moment aktiv zu werden, weil die EU-Kommission ja bereits angekündigt hat, dass sie nächstes Jahr so einen Gesetzesvorschlag präsentieren will. Wo ich im Moment relativ optimistisch bin, ist, dass das Europaparlament so was nicht zustimmen würde. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem wichtig, dass das Thema öffentlich präsent ist. Also ich glaube, in den Medien drüber zu reden, ist total wichtig. Auch mit seinen Abgeordneten drüber zu reden, ist wichtig. Ich fürchte halt, die Innenminister, also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es das, aber mir selber ist irgendwie noch nie eine Innenministerin oder ein Innenminister begegnet, der sich irgendwie besonders für den Schutz der Grundrechte engagiert. Insofern ist einfach meine Hoffnung ins Parlament viel, viel höher als in den Rat. Aber insofern würde ich sagen, ja es lohnt sich jetzt aktiv zu werden und eben vor allen Dingen einerseits die öffentliche Diskussion anzufachen. Das macht auch einen Eindruck auf die EU-Kommission, wenn sie irgendwie das Gefühl hat, das ist was, was ganz unpopulär ist. Als ich im Parlament war zum Beispiel, da hatten wir halt den Vizepräsidenten der EU-Kommission für Digitales, der immer ganz klipp und klar gesagt hat, also Hintertüren in Schlüsselungen kommen für ihn nicht in Frage. Es wäre natürlich total super, solche klaren Aussagen auch von der aktuellen Kommission zu bekommen. Ja, und bei den Europa-Abgeordneten, denke ich, ist man da auch nicht an der falschen Adresse. Weil da habe ich noch relativ große Hoffnung, dass die sowas tatsächlich ablehnen würden, wenn es dann so einen Vorschlag geben sollte.
Ja, also diese ganz konkreten Sachen, alles richtig. Ich wollte sozusagen einerseits sagen, Sinn macht das immer, weil die eine Seite, die pusht halt die ganze Zeit. Und wenn da niemand gegenhält, dann gehen die halt schrittchenweise vorwärts. Und alleine das ist gewissermaßen einfach der Grund, den wir haben, dagegen zu halten. Und das andere, die Älteren unter uns erinnern sich, dass die aktuelle Kommissionspräsidentin mal als Zensursula bekannt geworden ist und auch schon beim Thema Kinderpornografie sehr engagiert war und dann aber auch kräftig auf die Nase gefallen ist. Und ich finde das ein überraschender Zufall, dass dieselbe Person jetzt gerade wieder mit dem Thema Kinderpornografie in genau diesem Bereich Internet-Sicherheit und Überwachung große Schritte vorwärtsgehen soll. Und ich hoffe, dass das mithilft, da so ein paar Energien wieder zu mobilisieren, die seit einer Weile so ein bisschen vor sich hinschlafen. Also die Netzcommunity hier bei uns, die war schon mal aktiver. Das hat bei den Upload-Filtern zwischendurch noch mal wieder sich so ein bisschen bewegt. Aber es reicht einfach nicht, wenn wir uns zurücklehnen und sagen, ja, das haben wir immer schon gesagt, so ist es halt. Sondern tatsächlich ist es wahnsinnig nötig, jetzt aktiver zu werden. Einerseits wegen dieser EU-Aktivitäten und aber ja, weil wir das in Deutschland im Bereich des Bundestages und der Bundesregierung ganz genauso auch haben. Und übrigens ja auch demnächst ein Wahlkampf auf uns zukommt, wo es umso mehr wichtig ist, von allen Parteien ganz klare Aussagen zu fordern, wie sie sich zu diesen Dingen verhalten und ganz klar deutlich zu machen, dass diese Bewegung, die es da gab, die es in der Größe nicht mehr gibt, aber nicht völlig tot ist.
Ja, es ist ja auch so, dass solche Positionen oder Festlegungen ja auch immer wieder neu ausgehandelt werden müssen. Also was wir vor 20 Jahren gesprochen haben, inzwischen sind viele neue Leute im Parlament seit dieser Zeit. Es sind viele neue Leute in den Ministerien, viele neue Leute auch in der Kommission, die zum Teil diese Debatten gar nicht kennen. Und natürlich muss man deswegen auch diese Debatten regelmäßig immer wieder öffentlich führen, damit dann auch das Bewusstsein dafür geschaffen wird, dass es dadurch diese Probleme gibt. Denn natürlich ist das so ein Thema, was nicht einmal erledigt sein kann, sondern es wird immer wieder aufgemacht werden von verschiedenen Playern. Und da muss man halt dazu, ja, sich dafür einsetzen, dass es halt nicht kippt und wir dann quasi Regelungen kriegen, die wir nicht haben wollen.
Ich will nochmal an Julia und Anne fragen, weil, also Julia, du warst der Abgeordnete, Anne, du arbeitest für eine Fraktion im Bundestag. Dieses, man hört das ja immer, das ist immer sozusagen immer ein aktiven Ratschlag, den man bekommt, nämlich kontaktiert die Abgeordnete. Wie macht man das auf eine Art und Weise, wo man dann nicht in Verdacht gerät, okay, jetzt hab ich seine Mail hingeschrieben, aber ist auch egal, oder jemand angerufen, aber ist auch egal, gibt es dann einen Weg? Oder ist das sowas, wo man sagen muss, naja, du darfst jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass es deine Mail ist, dass es dein Anruf ist, sondern wenn das einfach du und 150 Leute machen, dann ist es halt krass und deswegen ist es halt wichtig, dass es jeder Einzelne macht. Oder als Konzept mal erklärt, weil ich kenne tatsächlich immer nur den einzelnen Ratschlag, aber nicht, wie es konkret funktioniert.
Also ich würde sagen, es kommt total drauf an. Wenn man E-Mails schickt oder in Abgeordnetenbüros anruft, dann ist es vergleichsweise selten der Fall, dass man dann direkt die Abgeordneten ans Telefon bekommt. Also kommt durchaus auch mal vor, aber meistens spricht man da mit dem Büro. Ein Weg, wie man tatsächlich dafür sorgt, dass das Thema bei den Abgeordneten selber ankommt, ist auf Wahlkampfveranstaltungen Fragen zu stellen. Das haben zum Beispiel bei der Europawahl 2019 ganz, ganz viele Leute gemacht. Also alle deutschen Europaabgeordneten wissen über das Thema Upload-Filter Bescheid, weil sie einfach im Europawahlkampf dutzende Male auf jeder kleinsten Wahlkampfveranstaltung irgendwo auf dem Land von jungen Leuten danach gefragt wurden. Und das macht auf jeden Fall einen Eindruck. Auf der anderen Seite will ich aber auch gar nicht Leute davon abhalten, auch mal Abgeordneten in Büros anzurufen. Ich glaube schon, dass das was bringt. Vor allen Dingen, weil auch gar nicht so viele Leute diese Möglichkeit in Anspruch nehmen. Also es ist schon so, zumindest im Europaparlament, dass wenn man da anruft und die Telefonnummern kann man auf der Webseite des Europaparlament nachschauen, dass man in der Regel schon jemanden ans Telefon bekommt und die sich dann zumindest auch so ein paar Minuten Zeit nehmen, um sich das Einlegen anzuhören. Es bringt natürlich immer mehr, wenn man irgendeinen Grund hat, warum das jetzt für diese Person relevant ist. Also wenn man zu einer bestimmten Interessengruppe gehört, am besten halt aus dem richtigen Wahlkreis kommt und sagt, ist für meine Wahlentscheidung relevant oder so. Oder man kann das Ganze natürlich auch über Verbände machen. Also wenn man irgendwie Mitglied ist in einer Gewerkschaft oder in einem Verein, kann man natürlich auch versuchen, diese Organisationen dazu zu bekommen, sich an Abgeordnete zu wenden, weil das natürlich nochmal einen größeren Impact hat. Also wenn ihr jetzt eine ganze Gewerkschaft oder einen ganzen Berufsverband aus dem Bereich IT-Sicherheit zum Beispiel so ein Schreiben schickt oder um einen Termin bittet, dann macht das natürlich auch nochmal mehr Eindruck.
Anne, im Bundestag genauso?
In Variation natürlich, klar. Das mit den Wahlkampfveranstaltungen finde ich auch eine sehr, sehr kluge Idee. Also Leute tatsächlich konkret bei solchen Gelegenheiten fragen, wo man dann direkt mit ihnen sprechen kann. Was oft gemacht wird, wo ich so ein bisschen skeptisch bin, sind so Massen-Mail-Aktionen. Das kann auch schon mal eine Wirksamkeit haben, wenn wo ankommt, dass da einfach wahnsinnig viele Leute sind, die sich für ein Thema interessieren. Das kann aber auch, also es gibt effektivere Methoden, würde ich sagen. Wir haben das jetzt gerade gesehen. Da ist das von den Querdenkern passiert zum Bevölkerungsschutzgesetz. Da ist der gesamte Bundestag mit Massenhaft-E-Mails komplett blockiert worden. Die Abgeordneten haben Tausende von den Dingern am Tag bekommen. Da kriegen die einfach nur mit. Da gibt es eine konzertierte Aktion. Da gibt es irgendeine Organisation dahinter. Aber da wird sowas sozusagen natürlich nicht einzeln gelesen und beantwortet, sondern nur mal registriert. Da gibt es viele Leute, die sich interessieren. Das kann auch effektiv sein. Wenn man tatsächlich selber eine Mail hinschreibt, ist es glaube ich schon den meisten Abgeordnetenbüros so, dass die so eine Policy haben, dass sie sagen, wir versuchen das auf irgendeine Art und Weise zu beantworten. Vielleicht nicht zwei Stunden Recherche, aber natürlich wird das gelesen und wird auch beantwortet. Und was, finde ich, viel zu wenig genutzt wird, ist der Versuch, ins Gespräch zu kommen oder eigene Anliegen vorzutragen. Das wird von Lobbyverbänden, Unternehmensverbänden total massiv gemacht, dass die ankommen und sagen, wir würden gerne mal mit ihnen ein Gespräch haben über dies, das und jenes. Und NGOs machen das von sich aus im Netzbereich quasi überhaupt nicht. Es gibt jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viele, und die sind alle unterausgestattet und haben auch wenig Zeit dafür und haben wahrscheinlich in ihren Projektförderungen für sowas auch kein Geld. Das ist schon auch alles klar. Aber dieses aktiv auf Abgeordnete zugehen und sagen, wir haben folgendes Anliegen. Wir wollen, dass sie sich für dies und das einsetzen. Wir erklären es ihnen auch gerne nochmal. Und hier ist noch ein Textbaustein, warum das wichtig ist. Das machen Verbände morgens, mittags und abends. Und AktivistInnen machen das nicht. Und das ist ein Riesenverlust.
Okay, also AktivistInnen, Verbände, mehr auf Japan und zugehen. Und alle Einzelpersonen, nächstes Jahr ist in Deutschland Wahlkampf.
Wenn ich da noch kurz einhaken, es gibt ja auch einfach nicht so viele. Aber natürlich können auch, wenn ich weiß, ich wohne irgendwo, das ist der Wahlkreis von Abgeordneten XY, kann ich mich ja auch mit ein paar Leuten zusammentun und sagen, wir sind hier interessierte BürgerInnen aus ihrem Wahlkreis. Und deswegen wollen wir mit ihnen mal reden. Und ich würde sagen, im Moment ist vielleicht sogar gerade eine besonders gute Gelegenheit, weil ja kaum Gespräche vor Ort stattfinden. Man muss nicht extra hinfahren, das dauert nicht drei Stunden, sondern sag, haben sie mal eine halbe Stunde Zeit für einen Videocall. Das ist ja viel einfacher, im Terminkalender unterzubringen.
Ich habe jetzt ganz zum Abschluss noch eine letzte Frage. Ich muss es ganz ehrlich zugeben, ein bisschen persönlich gefärbt. Ich habe es am Anfang angekündigt. Mir geht dieses Thema auf den Sack, um es so deutlich zu sagen, weil es wirklich eins von den Dingen ist, die eigentlich, wenn man sie sich einmal ausführlich erklären lässt, ganz klar sind. Verschlüsselung aufweichen ist Quatsch. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt heute für diesen Tag Mühe und Not meine Motivation zusammenkratzen können, um das nochmal zu erklären. Ihr seid jetzt alle gestandene Profis in dem Ding. Wie zur Hölle schafft ihr das, das aufrechtzuerhalten, das noch mal zu machen? Vor allen Dingen, wie Markus es erklärt hat, in dem festen Wissen, das wird nicht das letzte Mal sein.
Ich glaube, man sollte über das Ganze erklären und immer wieder diskutieren, die Nachwuchsförderung nicht vergessen. Ich glaube, es ist ganz wichtig, dass die digitalen Organisationen, die wir in Deutschland so haben, auch viel für die Nachwuchsförderung tun und gucken, dass junge Hacker und Hexen nachwachsen, die sich engagieren für diese Themen. Ich glaube, in dem Bereich könnten wir auch noch mehr machen. Als wir diese Diskussion zum ersten Mal geführt haben, da waren wir alle noch jung und engagiert. Da hat uns das vielleicht auch noch mehr Spaß gemacht. Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass die Szene immer wieder frische Unterstützung bekommt. Das heißt, auch die Leute, die sich in Vereinen engagieren und einfach coole Events machen, Nachwuchsförderungen machen und dafür sorgen, dass Leute mitmachen wollen, sind genauso wichtig, wenn nicht wichtiger, als die Leute, die sich die ganze Zeit mit Politikern streiten.
Es ist wichtig, das immer wieder wiederholen zu können, weil wir viele neue Leute dabei haben. Wenn man sieht, wer war vor zehn Jahren im Bundestag und ist heute noch im Bundestag, oder wer war vor 20 Jahren im Bundestag, oder welche Aktivisten sind heute auf Mail-Listen, die es vor zehn Jahren noch nicht gewesen sind, dann muss man diese Sachen immer wieder neu kommunizieren. Wir hatten ja auch in den letzten Chaos Congressen diese Einführungstalks, die an Anfänger gerichtet waren oder an Neulinge. Ich finde es ganz wichtig, dass man diese Themen auch immer wieder aufbereitet, damit neue Leute einsteigen können. Und da gibt es auch eine ganze Reihe von neuen NGOs, die jetzt schöne Dinge machen. Es gibt in Berlin zum Beispiel diese NGO Digitale Freiheit, die ganz tolle Kampagne gemacht hat zum Thema Gesichtserkennung. Das sind alles Leute, die vor fünf Jahren noch nicht in dem Bereich aktiv waren und sind jetzt völlig neu dabei. Wir haben auch gleich eine NGO aus Stuttgart, die regelmäßig Politiker-Gespräche gemacht hat. Also es gibt durchaus auch NGOs, die regelmäßig auf Politiker zugehen und das irgendwie koordiniert. Ähnliches macht ja auch EDI regelmäßig. Die sagen über ihre Mitgliederverbände, Menschen auffordern, sich in Brüssel zu melden, per Telefon, per E-Mail, per Web-Formular irgendwo. Und ich finde diesen Community-Gedanken wichtig und den müssen wir auch weiter ausbauen, wenn wir die Netzszene in diesem Bereich noch stärken wollen. Jetzt auch gerade in Corona-Zeiten kann man halt sehr viele Dinge von zu Hause aus machen. Wir können keine Großdemos machen. Also müssen wir andere Wege finden, um auch unsere Themen zu transportieren.
Die Frage war ja, was ist das Motiv, das immer wieder zu machen?
Das Motiv ist mir klar. Wie hält man die Motivation hoch?
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen pathetisch, aber Gerechtigkeitsbedürfnis, muss ich ehrlich mal sagen. Also wenn die Verschlüsselung kaputt ist, wenn die sichere Kommunikation noch viel weniger verfügbar und erreichbar ist, dann ist das ein Riesenproblem für total viele Leute, die von undifferenzierter Überwachung erwischt werden. Und da sind wir alle jetzt nicht unbedingt die, für die das das größte Problem ist. Wobei ich sagen muss, mich hat es davon auch schon mal ganz ordentlich erwischt. Das ist eine andere Geschichte, die einige vielleicht kennen. Das erwischt einen manchmal schneller als man denkt, aber gleichzeitig ist sichere Verschlüsselung, sichere Kommunikation für Leute, die in repressiveren Regimes leben, die unter viel schwierigen politischen Bedingungen leben. Und das rückt ja auch näher, Siehe Ungarn, Polen und so weiter. Kann das ein ganz riesengroßes Problem werden. Also sozusagen zu beobachten, wie Sicherheitsbehörden immer wieder auf allen Wegen versuchen, Überwachung auszubauen und Grundrechte abzubauen. Und zu verstehen, wie elementar überlebenswichtig es ist, dass es die gibt, international auch. Und das hat ja Auswirkungen, was hier passiert, dann auch auf den Rest der Welt. Blöde Formulierung, aber das sind schon Dinge, die mich da weiter sehr engagiert sein lassen und um die es einfach geht dabei.
Vielen Dank dafür. Vielen Dank euch allen dreien, dass ihr heute da wart und noch mal mit mir dieses Thema von vorne bis hinten durchgenommen habt. Es ist ein kleiner Trost für den Moderator, ich habe das grundsätzliche Thema schon oft behandelt, aber es ist immer eine andere Sendung gewesen, als ich wünschte. Ich müsste sie nicht mehr machen, aber vielleicht ist das ein kleiner Trost für mich. So, ihr da draußen habt es gehört, es ist ein wichtiges Thema. Es hilft nur, wenn man dran bleibt und man muss auch für Nachwuchs sorgen. Auch das ist ein Thema, das ist vielleicht immer so ein Intraschwerch dabei, aber vielleicht muss man das auch im Auge behalten. Also, Anne Roth, Julia Reda, Markus Drenger, vielen Dank euch, dass ihr heute hier wart. Liebes Publikum, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und der Spruch, den ich am Ende sage, ist heute wichtiger denn je. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.